hey everybody marcus here
in this video course i'm going to show
you how to build a full stack web
application step by step
so we're going to build a spring boot
based application
we're going to add a database and we're
going to add a web ui using botton
the application that we're going to
build is a crm application it'll feature
a login page using spring security so
that we can authenticate users
it'll have a list view where we can list
contacts in our system
and edit and delete them
you can also filter them
like this
it also has a dashboard view where you
can see the stats of the contacts in our
system
and finally we're going to turn this
into a pwa so that you can install this
on your
desktop or or device
we're also going to walk through
production deployment so how we can take
this application
uh change it to use a postgres database
and deploy it to heroku so that we can
share the link with anyone else
now
you can find
the uh text version of this tutorial on
vadim.com under docs
and be sure to go to version
21 or later there are some subtle
differences between 14 and 21 i'm gonna
go through the 21
and later version here if you're on
bottom 14 you can
change the version here and
follow the tutorial for that version
i'll add a link to the text version of
the tutorial and the source code in the
description below
if you have any kind of questions or
problems you run into issues while
you're working on the project please
join us on the vauden discord i'll also
add a link to that in the in the
description below and there you can chat
with the bottom community and and they
can usually help you figure out what's
what's not working in your project
so with that out of the way let's create
a new project and get going
[Music]
all right so the first thing we need to
do is download a project starter
for that either use the text version of
the tutorial and go to the project setup
chapter and click on download starter or
i will also add a link in the show notes
below
this will download a zip file
that you should extract then typically
it's good to move that out of your
download folder just so you have it so
we're safe and you don't accidentally
delete it the next thing we need to do
is open that up in a id i'm going to use
intellij throughout this tutorial but if
you're more familiar with another id you
can go ahead and use that instead
so i'll open the project by navigating
to the desktop selecting the folder and
clicking open
all right so we'll give this just a
minute to load all the dependencies that
it needs
and then we'll take a look at what we
have
all right so
let's open up the project and just take
a peek at the pom file which is the
maven project file so what we'll see is
that we have a spring boot project
using vaudin 21 in our case
and
if we look at the other dependencies
that we have here
you'll see that we have a h2 database so
that give us an in memory database that
we can use throughout the development
cycle here
we're gonna configure a postgres
database
uh when we go to production but for now
we're gonna use just the memory h2 for
easy development
we also have spring boot jpa for
accessing the database
and we have spring boot dev tools so
that we have live reload as we're coding
then if we take a look at the code here
in our java folder
we'll see that we have an application
class here which is the spring boot
application
and this is what we can
launch here to run the application so in
intellij you can go ahead and click on
the
run button here you could right click on
on the application itself and select
run on this
so you could select run here
or then you could use the maven default
command spring boot run
in order to run it through the command
line if you prefer to do that
now while that's starting up we can take
a look at the views that we have here so
right now as we're starting we have a
single view
so we have a view that is mapped to an
empty route extending vertical layout
displaying an image an h2 so a heading
level two and a paragraph of
text all being centered
the first time you run the application
it will take a couple of minutes because
the van build tool
will go ahead and download all the maven
dependencies that are needed
all the
front-end dependencies that are needed
through npm and then it's going to build
the front-end assets all of this happens
once
the first time you run the application
so it'll take a while but fortunately
it's not something you have to do
every every single time you start the
application
so
you can see the front end compilation is
starting now
this might take anywhere from a few
seconds to a few minutes depending on
your internet connection and your
and your uh
and your computer how fast it is
and while that's going on we can
kind of start sorting out our
workspace so we have
enough room here to to work with
all right so we can see now we have the
initial view here visible
mapping to this uh list view here that
we have
now one thing to note when you start the
application is that especially with
intellij it will start performing and
indexing
and
this will take
quite a while on on some computers
especially so this might take anywhere
from
from say 10 15 seconds to even a couple
minutes
while this indexing is going on
uh
your kind of experience will be a little
bit limited in that it won't
auto-complete and things like that won't
work
so we'll wait for the indexing to finish
then we'll make a small change to the
application and make sure that the live
reload works the way it's supposed to
all right so the indexing is
finished and let's just make sure live
reload works so i'll remove all the code
i had here
i'll type add so i'm going to add
something to the layout create a new h1
and type in the classic hello
world grading here
to get live reload to work i need to
build a project so depending on your id
it might be enough for you to save the
file or in intellij you need to actually
build it so it's either command or
control f9 or press the hammer icon here
will happen then this button will
uh notice that something has changed and
it will reload it and you can see that
we have the application
uh changes now visible here
all right so before we start building
anything let's take a quick look at what
bond is and how it works close to
download window here and go back to the
documentation here under design system
so one is a
component-based framework meaning that
we have a whole big library of these
ready to
use building blocks that we can use
anything from
input fields to combo boxes date pickers
number fields so on
we can use all of these by initializing
new components so for instance we could
do
a new button give it a caption like
click me
and we can then add this to the layout
so well first of all we could extract
this into a variable we could call it
button
and we can then when we're inside of a
layout we can call add to actually
display
a component in this case we can display
the button like this
and what will happen then is that it
will
show up here in our in our view
take a while to reload
and once it reloads so you can see we
have a button here
now
layouts are what determine how things
get displayed so if we were to add
another thing here so let's create a new
text field here
or capturing the name
and we'll have this can be called name
let's add
name here
to our
to our layout and see how that works out
all right so again we'll wait for the
live reload to kick in
and we'll see that we now have
the name and the button
on top of each other here
they're on top of each other because
they're inside of a vertical layout so
if we wanted to instead have them next
to each other
we could instead create a new horizontal
layout
and
add those to that instead so we could
add those to a horizontal layout
let's call this
hl for now and we'll instead add that
here to our main layout
and
again we'll wait for this to reload real
quick here
and you'll see that they're now next to
each other
obviously what you're also seeing is
that they're not quite aligned the way
you would hope them to be because
they're both aligned to the top of this
horizontal layout so
what you can do then is define how
things should be aligned here so you can
set for instance the default vertical
alignment
to in our case
baseline is a good
alignment so
aligning the baseline of the text
of both components that will make it
look kind of visually appealing
all right so now we have
the two components next to each other
aligned properly
the final part of kind of how one works
is to add
functionality by adding listeners so on
our button we can
add a click listener
so whenever
this button gets clicked we can decide
what we want to do
so here we could do for instance
we could show a notification
so
we'll actually need to be careful to
pull in the right notification so not
the javax management one
so we'll pull in the body and flow
component here
let's say show
and what we'll say is then hello
and we can get the name from the name
field
get value
like that
all right so now
we've created some components we've laid
them out using layouts and we've added
some functionality
by adding a listener for an event
so let's save this and make sure that it
works
all right
waiting for the reload to kick in
and then i'll type in my name
click the button and you can see we get
a notification saying hello marcus so
those are the basics of
working with boden everything is a
component so we can create components by
instantiating java classes
we layout components by putting them
into layouts like horizontal layout
vertical layout
and finally we add interaction by
listening for user events and reacting
to them
all right so now that you know some of
the basics of building a vauden
application let's start building out the
first view
so we'll uh go back to the
tutorial and
go to the creating a view chapter here
and what we're going to focus on here in
the first part of the tutorial is
building out
just this context list view so we're
going to get to the wrapping view here
with the navigation bar and everything
in in a little while but we'll just
focus on building out
this view here so we'll have a text
field we'll have a button and we'll have
a grid containing uh contacts
and if you're following along uh it
might be easier for you to just go and
copy the code from here instead of
trying to code along but i'll let you do
whatever you feel is is better for you
all right so uh
let's go into our app here
and i'll close the sidebar just so we
have more space for the code here
we'll begin by just removing all of the
code we have here
and then we'll start working from the
top down
so page title is what's going to be the
page title in the browser
uh for this particular page it's going
to be the contacts list so we're going
to call this contact
uh contacts and then we'll have a
pipe and just say bought in crm which
will be the application name
the route annotation means that this
view is mapped to the route uh the empty
route so essentially to the context
route
all right so with that we're ready to
start creating the components that we
need and as you may remember we'll need
a grid and a text field all right so the
first thing we'll create is that grid so
we'll have a
grid uh
that's going to hold contacts we'll call
this
grid
and this will be a new
grid
and we'll pass in contact.class here as
the parameter so the grid knows what
kind of objects we'll be working with
the other thing we need is a text field
so we'll create a new text field we'll
call this
filter text so we
know what we have in there and we
initialize this to a new text field
like that
all right so then we get to the
constructor and this is kind of where we
bootstrap our view where we start
creating things first thing i'll do and
what i like to do when i'm creating new
view is calling add class name and
giving this a css class name just so
if i end up writing css later on it's
going to make things a whole lot easier
so we'll call this
list view
all right then we're going to call set
size full
which will make this view the same size
as the entire browser window because
that way we can have that data grid
reach all the way to the bottom by
default a vertical layout would only be
as tall as the components inside of it
so that would leave some unused space at
the bottom which is not what we want to
do
then i'm going to call a new method
configure grid
to actually split out the configuration
of this grid and the way i like to do
that is just type out the method name
use the id
to generate the actual method
so
what are the things we need to configure
in this grid well first of all
i also like to add a class name
for this grid so i can style it later
so we'll call it contact
grid then
i'm going to call set size full on
this grid as well that way it's going to
take up all the space that's available
to it
next we're going to configure the
columns that we want to show so let's
take a look at the contact class here
and if you open up the sidebar here
you'll see that the starter that we
started with
has a data directory here
which contains
our entity classes so we have a contact
which is what we're looking at here
contains a first name a last name
a company
a status and an email
the company contains a name
and
a list of employees belonging to that
company and the status
is simply a name so in this case the
status of a contact might be something
like uh
closed lost or
or close one or similar to that
all right so anyway in this case we have
the fields first name last name company
status and email
so
when we
start configuring the grid here we can
tell it which columns we want to be
showing by default it would be showing
all the grids just as they are but we
want to configure them a little bit so
i'll call grid
and set
columns and this will take in strings
for the column name so i'll say
first
name
last name
and
email
i'll close that again
now
those are the primitive columns that we
had in there but we had a couple of
columns that contained
objects and if we just call set columns
like this
those would be just printed as as
whatever that object to string is and
that might may or may not be what you
want to do
so what we can do instead of just uh
setting the columns like this is define
a custom column so we can call grid and
we can call add column
and
what i will take in essentially
is a lambda that takes in the
contact
and should return a string then
that we want to display for that column
so in this case we're going to do
contact.getcompany.getname
to get the company name
and then we're going to call setheader
company so that way we have a
have a column showing the company uh by
getting its name we'll do the same for
the uh
for the status
so we'll call
red
dot add column
and we have the contact we call contact
contact dot get status dot get name
and then we'll
set the header to be
status like this actually going to
reorder these so we have the status
before the before the company
and the last thing i want to do
for configuring the grid is making sure
that all the columns get automatically
resized to a proper width we can do that
pretty easily by calling grid
and
calling get columns to get all the
columns and then for each of those
columns what we can do is call column
dot
set auto with to true
like that
so that way
we have configured the grid uh columns
that we want to show and then making
sure that all of them will be properly
sized to fit the content inside of them
right so that takes care of the grid
and
if you remember we're inside of a
vertical layout which means that
anything we add to this layout will be
placed on top of each other so
what we're going to do is we're going to
call
add and
have two things one will be the toolbar
with the
filter field
and the second one will be the grid for
the filter field i'm going to again
split this into a separate method just
to kind of keep the
keep the constructor nice and small and
kind of easy to understand
so we'll call get
toolbar
for getting that and then we'll pass in
the greatest the second component
first we need to again
generate this method
and this method should return the
component that we want to return for the
toolbar
so for the toolbar let's first of all
configure this text field that we have
so we'll call filtertext.setplaceholder
and the placeholder text we want to be
shown there is
filter by name
then uh we're gonna set the clear button
visibility to true so that way if
there's something written in the text
field somebody can just click on the
clear button and clear all of that out
we're also gonna optimize this a little
bit by
setting
the value change mode
to lazy
so what this essentially means is that a
little bit later in the tutorial when we
start actually implementing the
filtering we don't want to actually hit
the database on every single keystroke
we want
to kind of
wait for the for the user to stop typing
for a little while so that we don't
unnecessarily keep fetching everything
uh from the database on every keystroke
all right so that takes care of sorting
out the
uh filtering text field
the other thing we need there is a
button for adding new contacts so we'll
create a
new button
and the text here will be just add
contact
and i'll extract this into a variable
and the other variable can just be like
add contact
let's say add contact button like this
and then
because we want these two components to
be next to each other we need a
horizontal layout to wrap those
so i will create a new
horizontal layout
pass in the filter text field and the
add contact button
i'll extract this into a
toolbar
variable and then i'll take the toolbar
add a class name to this because i need
it for css later so we'll call this
toolbar
and then finally we will return
this one toolbar
all right so if we look at what's
happening now is that when a user
navigates to the context root of the
application this view will get
initialized it's a vertical layout so
everything inside of it will be
displayed on top of each other
we make the layout full size
we configure the grid columns and then
finally we add two components to the
grid we
get the toolbar component which has a
horizontal layout with the
text field and the button and then the
grid is the second component here
again let's uh
build this and take a look at what we
get in the browser to make sure that
we're on the right track
and we'll wait for the reload to finish
and what we should see right now is that
we have the filter toolbar up here and
we have an empty grid here
the way we'll approach this is that
we'll
create all the ui components we need for
this view first and then we'll start
looking at
creating the back-end implementation
that we need for actually populating and
updating and saving and all of that
all right so the next thing we're going
to do is create the editor for the
individual contact so
in the text version we're going to go to
the next chapter and you can see that
we're working on this part of the
application right now so the form where
you can see and edit contact details
again if you're uh following the text
version you can copy the entire code but
i'll walk you through the implementation
in the ide
so
what we're going to do is open up
the sidebar here
and navigate into the list view
package here and we're going to create a
new component
we create a new component by creating a
new java class and i'm going to call
this contact form because it's a form
for editing contacts
and i'm going to add this to my
get all right so contact form will
extend
not from vertical layout or horizontal
layout but from
form layout which is a layout in bottom
that's suited for creating forms it will
it will responsibly either have one or
two columns depending on how wide your
viewport is
creating these own components is
something that's very common when you're
building bottom applications so you can
build compositions of existing
components and essentially create your
own
custom components that you can use in
the application so in the case of our
form what we'll do is we'll create input
fields for all the properties of our
contact and then we'll display them in
this form layout and we'll add some
buttons for things like saving deleting
and closing
right so i'll just start from the top
create a text field for
first name
and this will be a new text field first
name
we'll create another text field for last
name
and that'll be also a new
text field
last name
then we'll create a email field
field
called
email and that will map to a new email
field so you can kind of see these field
names map pretty much one to one to the
underlying contact object and we're
gonna get to that in a in a moment
so we'll give this a caption of email
then what we'll need for the status and
the company are essentially like these
drop down selects for that i'm gonna use
a combo box
and the combo box type
will be a status for the status select
and here again we want to make sure we
get the right status so the one in our
application
and this will be a new
combo box
status
and finally a combo box for the company
it's equal to a new combo box for
company
like this
all right um
so like i kind of hinted earlier there's
a reason why i named these exactly the
way i did
and that is if we look at the
contact entity that we're binding to
if these have the same names as our as
our entity below we're going to be able
to use the bottom binder later to tie
those together automatically
all right so
now we have the the fields created here
let's create a new
constructor for the contact form so
we'll
generate a constructor
and just the empty constructor right now
we're not going to
take in anything here
essentially we're not going to pass in
any of the the field values here
what we do want to pass in or taken as
as parameters here are
the companies and statuses that we want
to list in these so we'll add two
parameters that we
expect the user of this component to
pass in so we'll have a
list of
company objects which will be the
companies
and then we'll have a list of
statuses
which will be the statuses
all right and
then we can start kind of configuring
this form component so
first of all i'm gonna do the same thing
as for everything so far i'll add a
class name
contact form
then
i will take the company
combo box and i'm gonna call set items
and i'm gonna pass in those companies
that we got from the constructor
so these ones
because these are our objects i want to
tell the combo box what property from
there i want to
show as the as the visible property so
i'm going to call
company
that's set
item label generator
and use the company name getter for that
we're going to do the exact same for
statuses
so set items
passing the statuses
then we're going to set the
item
generator
to
status
get name
like that
all right and then we're gonna add
all these components to the layout so
we're gonna call add
and we're gonna just start with the
first name
that's the last name
email then we'll have the
company drop down finally the status
drop down
and then we're gonna create a buttons
layout for the save delete and close
buttons so we're gonna
split this out into a method of its own
just to keep the the add method here
nice and clean so we'll create a new
method called create
buttons
layout
and we will obviously need to implement
this so we're going to create the method
it will return a component
right so for the buttons layout we'll
first of all need some buttons so we'll
go up here and create some buttons so i
have
a
save button which will be a new
button with the caption
save
then we'll copy this and create two
others so we'll have one for
delete
and one for cancel
like this all right and
once we have those we can go and
configure them so for the save button
what i want to do is call
add theme variant and we're going to use
the button variant primary for this
which will make it stand out be clear
that's the primary action that we expect
people to do
the delete button will add
the theme variant
error so again use the button variant
and select the error one and then
finally for the cancel button
we're gonna add the theme variant
tertiary
like that
okay um
then i'm gonna add some click shortcuts
so people using the keyboard can use
these more efficiently so for the save
button we want to add the click shortcut
enter
and for the cancel button we want to add
the shortcut
escape
like that
then what we return from this will be a
horizontal layout
so we want them to be horizontally next
to each other new
horizontal layout and we'll
pass in the save
the delete
and the cancel buttons
like that
all right so now we have a a form that
contains input fields for
all the properties of a contact and we
have buttons for saving deleting and
canceling
now just having this form will
of course not kind of make it show up in
our application we need to go back to
our list view here and add it to the
layout
so let's do that next all right so back
in our list view let's create a field
for the contact form so we'll create a
new field here called form
and then i'm going to add
another
configuration method here so call this
configure
figure
form
form
implement this
and in here i first of all need to
initialize the form so the form will be
equal to a
new contact form and as you remember it
takes in
two lists now at this point we haven't
connected to the backend yet so we don't
have any actual lists of companies and
statuses so what i'll do just in for a
placeholder right now is use
uh
collections.emptylist to just
pass into empty
uh
to emptylist
collections.emptylist like this and
we'll replace those with the actual
lists in just a moment
and then i'm going to give this form a
width of
25 ems so that has a width
all right and
what i want to change then instead
instead of passing in the grid here
directly we're going to create another
kind of helper method for configuring
this so we're going to instead of
passing in the grid here we're going to
create a new method called get
content
and
in this method what i want to do is
create a wrapper layout a horizontal
layout that holds both the grid and the
form next to each other
so
what i'll do here is i'll first of all
create a new horizontal layout and pass
in both the grid and the form
and i'm going to call this content
then i'm going to define how these two
will kind of uh be spaced so by calling
content
that set flex grow we can tell how they
uh how the space should be allocated
between these so i wanna say that the
grid should get two
uh thirds of the space and then
the
form should get one third of the
space like this
so two and one
for the flex grow here
also for for this uh layout i want to
add a class name so i'm going to call
add class name
and say
content will be
be a good class name there and finally
let's call set size pull on this so that
the contents the right size
and then start instead of null we're
gonna pass in the content here
all right
so again if we look at what we did we
have a field here for the form
we configure the form by instantiating a
new form passing in to empty collections
for now
then we pass into the view two
components the toolbar which we had from
before and then a content which is a
horizontal layout containing the grid
and the form next to each other
so if we go into the browser we can see
right now that we have the grid we have
the form here on the side and we have
the toolbar on the top so
we right now have all the ui components
that we need for this view the next step
for us will be to connect this to our
database and display and work with some
actual data
so up until now we've taken a look at
the contact entity that we have but
let's take a look at some of the other
stuff that we have from our starter
so in addition to the actual jpa entity
classes that we have here
we have repository interfaces for each
of those
so with the help of these spring boot
and spring data will give us the basic
create read update and delete operations
that we need
all right so in addition to those we
have a data generator
that generates us some test data that we
can work with so that way when we start
accessing the database we already have
some some context there to work with now
in order to hook up to the database
there are two different ways we could go
about doing it we could either just use
the repositories directly to access the
database
but in this case it's a better practice
for us to create a service class that
works as a middleman here
running some business logic and kind of
ensuring that we're not accessing the
database directly from the ui layer
so i'm going to create a
new class here called crm service
and
this will be a spring service class so
we'll annotate it with a service
annotation
and
what we'll have here is first of all
we'll need to have a constructor where
we auto wire in all those repositories
that we need
so we'll have the
contact repository
then we'll have the
company repository
and finally we'll have the status
repository like this
then i'm going to use the id
to bind these to fields
all of them like that
so that way we'll have access to all of
these
so this service class will essentially
have all the apis that we'll use to
connect to the database
in our application
so the first thing i want to implement
here as our public api is a method to
find context based on a filter text
so let's create a new method here
that returns a list
of contacts
and i'll call this
find all contacts
that match
a string
filter text like this
and
here let's check first of all if
filter text is null
or if the
filter text is empty
then
we will return
the
contact repository
find all so just return all of the
contacts in our in our database
else
we're gonna
do a research so we're gonna
return the value we get from calling
again the contact repository
dot search
and pass in
the filter text
now this is not something that exists
yet so we need to go ahead and
add this
and here what i'll do is i'll use a jpql
query
now i'm slightly
lazy i'm not going to type up the whole
query so
i'll go here to the
to the text version and copy this over
and then explain what's happening
so
what we do here essentially is that we
name this uh search term here as a
parameter
and then we use it in a query where we
select contacts where the first name or
the last name matches that search term
uh and we turn everything into lowercase
so it's case insensitive
all right
so that takes care of the first piece of
the api so we have one way of finding
contacts so if we don't have a filter we
return everything and if we have a
filter text we use that query to filter
them
next thing will be pretty easy we'll
have a
public method again returning a
long
called count
contacts
and this will return
context repository.count
all right
next one will be for deleting contacts
so
it can be a void method
delete contact
and this takes in the contact that we
want to delete
and
what this will do then is again delegate
to the
contact repository
to delete
this contact
like so
then we'll do the same
for saving contacts so we'll create
again a method
for save contact
taking in a contact
and what we'll do here is first of all
let's just make sure that we actually
got a contact in because sometimes if
you mess up with the binder it's easy to
pass in a null value here and we'll make
our life easier if we check for that so
let's uh
print out to the system error log
that contact is null
so assuming as we
actually have a contact we can delegate
again to the contact repository to save
this contact like so
good all right so that takes care of all
the contact related ones that we need
then let's create one for finding
companies
so again a public method that returns a
list of
company objects
called find
all companies
and this will return the company
repository.find all and finally we'll
create a similar function for statuses
so we'll create a method that returns a
list of
status objects find
all statuses
and delegate this again to the status
repository find all method like that all
right so now we have a service class
here that takes in all these
repositories in the constructor uh
through auto wire
we have a way of finding contacts with a
filter text content contacts deleting a
saving contacts and then finding all the
companies and statuses
all right so now that we have this
service here we can go back to our list
view and
start using it
first thing we need to do is auto wire
it so we have access to it
in our view so we'll pass in the crm
service here
we can call this service
and we'll
create a field for this so we have
access to it throughout the entire
entire view
then
as the last thing here i will call a new
method
update list which
we'll use to update the list of contacts
so we'll create this method
and what update list will do is it will
call grid
that's set items
and the items we'll get from calling
service
find all contacts and then we need to
pass in the filter
value which we can get from the filter
text field
get value
right so
whenever we call update list we'll go to
the database and fetch all the contexts
that match this filter that we have
currently
all right then we also need to hook up
the filter text field
uh to actually filter as we're typing
so we go here into our toolbar we'll
call filter text we'll add a value
change listener
and whenever that happens we call update
list
and as you remember we're using this
lazy value change mode so it waits for
the user to stop typing for a little
while before it does that
and then finally let's go here to the
contact form and replace the companies
and statuses with their actual content
so we use the service to find all
companies and then we'll
use the service
to find all statuses like this
right so let's hit build let's build the
application and
see if everything worked out so we'll
go into our app here and what we can see
now is that we have all the
contacts here we should be able to
filter them so let's start typing in the
first name here
and sure enough that filters them down
we can clear the filter and that shows
all of them
what we should also see
is the companies and the statuses that
we passed in here
the next thing we want to do is
hook up the form so that when we select
people in the grid the right person gets
selected in the form and that we can
edit them we're going to do this in two
parts so first what we'll do is we'll
hook up the data binding in the form so
that we can
both edit and validate the input and
trigger events from this form and then
once we have that done we'll hook up
this form
uh to the grid so that whenever we
select a
contact in the grid they'll get selected
here
on the side
all right so let's begin by setting up
the form here
for that we're going to go back into the
contact form class
and create a binder
so let's create a new binder here
a binder is something the bottom uses
for binding between a model object and
ui components so in this case we're
going to work with contacts
and we'll call this binder
and we'll initialize this to a new
bean
bean validation binder
and this will similarly to the grid
taken the contact class as a parameter
now what a bean validation binder will
do is it will
use bean validation annotations on the
class that we have
to provide validation also in the ui
so all of these not empty
not null
and like email
validations
will also get used in the ui so that way
we don't have to write the same
validations twice once in the ui and
once in the back end
all right so with the binder created
we need to call it as well
so here in the
in the constructor i will add a
call to binder dot
bind instance fields and pass in this
and this is where the naming comes in so
as you remember we named
the fields here exactly the same as the
field names in the contact so that way
the binder will take care of
binding the first name property
of the uh
of the contact to the first name text
field and so on
all right so now that we have the binder
taken care of let's add an api
that we can use from from the view to
set the currently selected contact
so let's go and create a new
method here
and we'll call this public method
set contact
and this will take in a contact
and what we'll do here is we'll save the
contact to a field
called contact
and then we'll call the binder
to read this contact bean
so that means the binder will
read this
bean that we pass in and populate these
ui fields based on it
all right so now that we have a way of
passing in a contact
and a way of binding the values from
that contact to the ui fields the next
thing i want to do is define a couple of
events that this form can fire and that
way kind of inform the view when
something has happened so especially we
want
a save event a delete event and a close
event
for this we're gonna use one component
events and if we go again into the text
version here into the forms and
validation chapter
you can see that we have
a bunch of events here that i'll copy
over and then walk you through
so we'll
fix the imports here
we need to take the button flow
registration here i'll close the sidebar
so we can see
this whole thing
so
what we essentially do is first of all
we create a base
class for
events
that we emit from this forum
and we extend from the basic component
event
that vaden provides
we add a field for
storing the contact that we're working
with so whether we're saving or deleting
that contact we can save it here
then we create specific events for
saving deleting and closing passing in
that contact
to those events so that we can get hold
of the content when we're
listening to those events in the list
view
finally we have a addlistener method
here that takes in the event type
and the listener and adds them to the
van eventbus
all right so now we have most of the
pieces that we need to make this form a
fully functional component we have a way
of passing in the contact a way of
binding it to the ui fields the
remaining piece of the puzzle is to hook
up
the save functionality and the delete
and close buttons to actually fire the
appropriate events so for that we're
going to go
into the
button layout
method here and we'll start just binding
these so
so we'll add a
click listener
on the save button
and
on the click event what we want to do is
we want to call a new method called
validate
and
save
so there's a little bit more
going on in the validation so i don't
want to do it inside the lambda i'll
just split it out into a
into a separate method here so what i do
here in validate and save is that first
of all i'll
try
to call
binder dot right bean
and we'll write the value from the
binder back to that contact that we
saved in a field
then
we need to add a catch for the
validation exception here for now i'm
just going to print the stack trace
in a real more kind of real life
application we probably want to show
some sort of visual notification to the
user
but assuming that we get past this we
now have a
valid saved contact and what we want to
do is kind of call fire event
and we want to create a new
save event
and
this will take in two things so the
source component which will be this and
it will take in the contact which is the
contact
right so now we have the save button
hooked up to
both
validating and saving
the value from binder to the contact and
firing an event
next let's do the same for the delete
button so again add a click listener
and here the event should just call fire
event
create a new delete
event we pass in this and the contact
then we do the close button
or sorry the cancel button we add a
click listener
and here we call fire event
new
close event
and we pass in this
in this case it doesn't make any
difference what what the contact is if
we just want to
uh close out of this
all right so now we have
a complete api for our form we have
a way of setting a contact
whenever we set the contact the binder
reads that bean because it's bound here
to the instance fields that means that
it will populate all the ui fields with
that
and then we hooked up the button so that
whenever we save or delete or cancel we
fire an event
so at this point
we just want to build and make sure
everything works there's no visual kind
of
changes to our application so far so
what we need to do next is go to the
list view and hook it up so that
whenever we change the selected contact
here or click add contact the right
contact gets
populated here and whenever we save or
delete we actually want to do those save
and delete options
operations to the back end
okay so let's jump into the
into the list view again and see how we
can manage the view state so by the view
state i mean that when we select a
contact we want to
show that editor with the right contact
when we close the form we want it to
actually get hidden and when we either
save or delete the contact we want those
to be hooked up to the back end
okay so first thing i want to do is
start
the view off in the right
state so with that i mean that when we
don't when we start the application we
don't have a selected contact so we
shouldn't be showing the form so we're
going to call a new method called
close
editor
and
what close editor does
is it
calls the forms
set contact with
null
then we'll call form.setvisible
also we hide the form
and then finally what we'll do is we'll
remove a classname
of
editing
that's something we'll add when we start
editing and the reason for that is we'll
add some responsive styling so that when
we're editing on a narrow screen we can
hide the grid and the toolbar to give
all the space available just to the form
all right so now that we start
the application we navigate to this view
we start off in the right state so we've
closed the editor
and
we don't see the forum because we don't
have anyone selected
so the next thing we want to do then is
handle somebody getting selected
so for that let's go into the configure
grid method here
and then
we'll add a listener so we'll take the
grid
as a single select so grid
supports both multi and single select
modes because we only want to select one
component one contact we can use the
single select and add a value change
listener here all right so when this
happened what we want to do is we want
to call again a new method
edit
contact and then we get the
value from from the event like this
and again we'll
create the method here
and we'll call this
contact
all right so what we need to do here is
handle two different cases one is the
the contact maybe null so if somebody
deselects a selected contact
we need to close the editor so that we
already have
good
and
in other cases we need to do something
about this
so essentially we need to do more or
less the opposite of what we did just a
while ago so we call
form that set contact we pass in
the contact
and then we
set the visibility to true because we
want it to be shown and then we add a
class name
of editing
here so that we can use that for our
responsive styling in in just a moment
all right so now we have hopefully a way
of selecting a person in the grid let's
uh build this and
see that that works so now we can see
that when we start the app we don't see
the form
and when we select somebody
in the in the grid we can see the right
person
getting shown here and if we click the
same person again to unselect it hides
them
all right so next up let's hook up the
add contact button here
so for that we'll go into the get
toolbar method here and we have the add
contact button already created so we'll
take that add a click listener
and for that we want to call add contact
and we want to create the method
here what we want to do is we want to
take the grid
a single select again and clear it
meaning that when we create a new
contact we don't want a different
content to be selected in the grid
because that would be slightly confusing
to the user and then once we've cleared
the grid we can call
edit contact and create a new
contact object so start off with a clean
slate
all right so we'll save this again
just make sure that we're
on the right track everything is working
the reload is
is kicking off here so we we can still
select people here and we can create a
new contact by
clicking the add contact here
now i hinted towards making some
responsive styles so right now if we're
on a very narrow screen you can see that
this isn't really an optimal
use of space here we it would be better
if we could just have the entire space
available here for the form so for that
we can add some css
and again
we're gonna cheat a little bit and go to
the text version and copy those styles
so
we're gonna go
here we're gonna copy these and we're
gonna put them in the
theme folder so
we're gonna go into the frontend
directory
to the
themes and select the style css here
right now you can see it's only only
pulling in some some icons and we'll add
our own style here beneath that
alright so what the style does is that
it adds four narrow viewports
on the list view whenever the editing
class name is present it will hide both
the toolbar and the con
contact grid
so we'll uh go ahead and save this
and then we'll go back to the
application and and see if that got
picked up and works
so we'll uh
refresh this
and we'll see if this works so now that
you now you can see that when we go on a
narrow screen
we can actually get the entire screen
uh as real estate available for the form
which is much nicer now of course we
need to have a way of getting out of
this and that's the next thing we're
gonna do so we're going to hook up all
these buttons to actually do something
so again we'll go into the list view
and here we're going to go into the
configure form
method and we're going to add listeners
on the forum for those custom events
that we we created first event i'm going
to hook up is the save event so i'll
take the form we'll add a listener for
the
save event
dot class
and then we're going to hook it up to a
new method on
this called save
contact
then we'll create a new
method for this it's going to be a
private method
void
would save contact
this takes in
the save event i'll call this event
and what we want to do here is then use
the service to save the contact
by getting it from the event
like that
once that's done we can call update list
to make sure that all the updated data
gets shown and then we'll call close
editor like that
all right so that takes care of saving
next we'll take the form
add a listener for the delete event
and again we're going to take the class
and then we'll create
this dot
delete
contact
and similarly we'll create a new private
method for that
taking in the delete
delete event
and what we want to do again is defer to
the service to delete the contact so
again we can get that from the event
and then we want to call update list to
make sure that list is up to date and
then we want to close the editor like
that
then finally we want to add a listener
for the
close event
and this one will be easier because we
only need to call
close editor
like that
so now we have
those events hooked up here
so that whenever we save or delete we
defer to the
defer to the service and
close the editor whenever we do anything
so let's try this out
let's change
a contact here click save we can see
that that gets shown here
we can delete that person
and they disappear from there
and finally we can try out the close
here so if we click on cancel when we're
editing especially on a narrow screen we
can see that that
hides the form as expected
so up until now we've only been working
on the list view the next thing that
we're going to look at is adding a app
layout that has this responsive drawer
with navigation links and a header and
that will allow us to then add a second
view for a dashboard that shows stats
over the context that we have
so in order to add this main layout
we're going to go into our java code
again to the views package and i'm going
to create a new java class here called
main layout
and main layout will extend from app
layout
which is a one class
that implements that drawer layout
in here i'm going to implement the
constructor and essentially split out
two helper methods one for creating the
header and one for creating a drawer
i'll call
create
header
and create
draw or like that
and
go ahead and create these methods
like that
and we'll start implementing them so for
the header we're creating a new h1 so
just a header level one
that says bought in
crm
and we can extract this into a
into a variable called logo
and for logo i will add a couple of
class names
the ones i will add is
text l
and
margin medium
the class names here are part of the new
utility classes in the vauden
lumo
design system
so you can find
all of these described here under the
design system documentation if you
if you want to use some of the other
ones in your application later on
all right so we have the logo we've
adjusted the text size then and the
margin
and then what we'll do is create a new
horizontal layout to hold on to
everything that's going to go into that
header so i'll create a new
horizontal layout and we'll pass in a
new
drawer toggle which is something
the app layout uses for toggling the
drawer and then the logo
and
this will be the actual
header itself
then for the header
we want to get set the default
vertical component alignment to center
to make sure everything's nicely aligned
we want to call
expend
on the logo meaning that the logo should
take up all the extra space
in this layout
we'll need that a little bit later on
when we add add the logout button
then we'll set the header
width to full
like that
and then i'm gonna add some utility
class names to this one as well so i'm
gonna call add class names
put the padding in the y-axis to zero
and the padding in the x-axis to medium
with the header configured i'm going to
call add to navbar
and pass in the header so this is
perhaps a little unintuitive that the
slot that we're using for the header is
actually
called the nav bar according to the
to the
app layout whereas the drawer is what we
will use as our nav bar
so the drawer then is where we have the
links to the different views
here we'll create a new
router link
which is something that we can
use to to navigate to a view so we'll
give it a caption list
and this will navigate to list view
dot class
all right so that'll be the list view
and for the list view we'll
set the highlight
condition
to
highlight conditions
i like
conditions dot
same location
the reason i'm setting this is that for
the
default path the empty path essentially
that would match
any path because every path starts with
an empty path so this is something we we
need to have here just so it doesn't
stay highlighted uh because it thinks
every every other
view essentially in our application
would be a sub sub view of this
alright so once we have that we're gonna
add
to drawer and we're going to create a
new vertical layout so we want the
links to be vertically aligned on top of
each other and we'll pass in the list
view link here now that we have the
highlight conditions here on on the
links the other thing we need to do is
define how we want to style those so
go into the text version again copy some
css here
and we're going to
go into the front-end folder once again
into the theme folder
the style css and add this style so any
time a link has to highlight that
tribute we're gonna bold and underline
it
right so with the main view now created
we need to go into the list view and
tell it to use this main layout
so
here where we have the route
we need to add a
layout
parameter and set this to be
main
layout.class
this way
whenever this view gets loaded it will
get loaded inside of main layout
so
let's build this and go into the
application and see that what we have
looks somewhat to be on the right track
so you can see we now have the header
here we have the drawer toggle that we
can use to toggle this drawer and we
have the
link here and it's highlighted so it's
bold and underlined so that looks good
now that we have the main layout in
place and we have a place to actually
had to have links to different views
we're ready to add another view to our
application so for that i'm going to go
into the views package
here my java source and create a new
java class
i'm going to call this dashboard view
and dashboard view will extend from
vertical layout the same as list view
we're going to give this a route
annotation where the value
is equal to
dashboard
and the layout is equal to the same main
layout.class
we're also going to give this a page
title
this will be
dashboard
we'll have the same
login
crm alright so the dashboard view if we
kind of look at what we're aiming to do
will look something like this so we'll
have the amount of contacts we have in
our
in our system and then a pie chart
showing how those different contacts are
split into different companies
so here in our class let's create a new
constructor first of all
and here we will auto wire in the crm
service
we'll call it the service
and save it into a field
called service like this
and then
i'm going to give this a class name the
same list we've done for everything so
far so add class name
dash board
view
then i'm going to
set the default component alignment to
center so we want everything to be
centered
horizontally in this vertical layout
and then we're going to call add
and create two helpers again so one for
get
contact
stats
and one for get
companies
companies
chart like that
right so we'll go ahead and
create these methods
like that
and let me just
rearrange these so they're in the same
order
so we'll start with the easier one so
get context set so here we need to just
show essentially a text with the how
many contacts we have in the system so
for that we can use a span
just a plain html span
and here the number of contacts we can
get from the service by getting count
contacts
and calling plus
contacts to concatenate a string
so this will be our
stats essentially
first sets we'll add some class names
again
to configure how it looks so we can use
text extra large
and then
i'll set the margin top
to be medium so it doesn't quite touch
the top there
and then we'll return
the stats here
all right then for the companies chart
we need to do a little bit more
so for the chart itself we're going to
use bottom charts which is part of the
pro library so if you're doing this
tutorial and you want to try it out
there's a free 14 day date trial or if
you're a student it's part of the free
student package so you can get it from
there as well
so we're going to create a new chart
and this will be of chart type
pi
and
this chart
will then need to get its data somewhere
so for that we need a new
data series
and we're just going to
pull this out into variable
and then what we need to do is
call
service
find all the companies
and then for each of them
kind of pull out the stats so for each
company
what we can do here is
call
data series dot add
create a new
data series item
and this takes in two things essentially
the it'll be the company name and then
the account of employees in the company
so we'll take
company dot get name
and then
company dot
get employee
count and that's something that doesn't
exist yet that we need to create for
that let's go to the text version here
and copy a little bit and then i'll
explain what's happening so
we'll go into the
into the company
uh class that we have so in in data
entity company
we'll go here and we'll add
this employee count now there are
essentially like two ways we could have
gone about getting the count of
employees we could have actually fetched
all the employees from the database and
counted them but that's not very
efficient because we only needed to know
how many there are so instead we can use
a formula to just count how many there
are and have a getter that
calls that
so now we have
added a series item
where we get the name and the amount of
employees in each company here
and the final thing that we need to do
then is we need to take the chart
we need to get the configuration and we
need to set
this series
to this data series that we have
like this
and then finally of course we need to
return this chart
so again if we look at the big picture
here what happens is that we
have a vertical layout that centers
everything on the horizontal axis
we add two components a span containing
stats so just the total number of
contacts in our system and then the
other one being a chart which is a pie
chart
that pulls from the
service all the companies and then uses
the formula to get the employee count in
each
so let's save and build this
and right now
if we
go to our application we should be able
to go to
dashboard
and see it here so the dashboard view
itself now works obviously we want to
add it here to the main layout so let's
finalize this dashboard view
implementation by going into the main
layout and then adding it here so for
that we're just gonna inline it here
we're gonna do a new
router link
to
dashboard
and that will navigate to
dashboardview.class
save and
build go to the application
see that we now have the dashboard view
here it's highlighted because we're on
the dashboard view we can go to the list
view
let's go here
delete one contact go here verify that
the number of contacts here has actually
been updated which it has so that looks
good we now have two views in our
application and we can navigate
between them up until now everyone could
access everything in our application and
that's not what we want to do so next
let's secure the application with spring
security and add a login screen
so
we're going to begin by creating the
login screen so here in the views
package we're going to create a new java
class and we're going to call this login
view
and login view will extend from vertical
layout the same way as other
views that we've had so far so vertical
layout and we're going to implement
the before
enter listener so that way we can hook
on to the before enter event
and we'll get back to that in in just a
second
so first of all let's
add a couple of annotations here so
first one being the route annotation
we're going to map this to the login
route and then we're going to give it a
page title
that will be
login and then a pipe and bought in crm
all right then what we're going to do is
we're going to override the constructor
and in the constructor we're going to
start constructing the view
for the actual login we're going to use
a login view component so i'm going to
instantiate it up here i have a private
login form
we can call this the login and that will
be equal to a new login form
then in the constructor we're going to
add a class name
login view
we will set the size to full
and then we'll align components both in
the horizontal and vertical
direction so we'll
set the
set the line items to center and then
we'll
also set justify content mode to center
center so that everything's centered
then we're going to configure the login
action so where this login form should
post to
and that will be the login path
and then finally we'll add the
components to the layout with add
we'll create a new
h1 with saying bought in crm so people
know what they're logging into and then
the login form
all right and in the before enter
listener here what we want to do is
check if the url has a error query
parameter and if so we're going to show
that error
so
if
the
before enter event
dot get location
dot get query parameters that get
parameters
contains a key
called
error we know that we have an error that
we should show so we'll take the login
form
and set the error to true
like that
okay so
save and build
and what should happen right now is that
we should have the login view available
but it's not enabled yet so there's
nothing that forces us to go there but
we can
navigate there manually because we
didn't use the parent layout you can see
that we don't have the wrapping app
layout here we just have the login form
and that's exactly what we want
okay so the next step will be to
actually enable spring security for that
we need to first
install a dependency so we will go into
the pom file
and we need to install the spring boot
starter security
dependency so just going to
copy this over and change validation to
security
like that then it's important to
actually
fetch the maven dependencies so
go ahead and do that before continuing
and once that is done
we need to turn off the server and
restart it because otherwise those won't
get picked up
so while that's happening we can start
configuring spring security
for that we're going to go into our
application package here
and we're going to create a new package
we're going to create a new package
called security
and here we're going to create
a class called security config
where we can configure how spring
security should work because right now
you can see it's not using our login
view it's using spring security's
default login view which doesn't look as
nice
all right so how do we use this security
config first of all we need to tell
spring to enable like security and then
we're gonna tell that this is the
configuration that we want to use
then we're going to extend from
bottom
uh web security configure adapter quite
a mouthful but that's the kind of naming
convention that's used here
let's uh hide the sidebar so we have a
little bit more space to work with here
and we need to override a couple of
methods here so
so we're going to override configure
for http security
and we need to make sure that we call
super.configure to let the vadin web
security configure adapter do its thing
and then we are going to set the login
view to login
view dot class so that way we're gonna
use our
our own login view and we actually need
to pass in the http configuration object
there as well
all right so that configures
one thing the other thing we want to do
is we want to exclude an image directory
from spring security altogether we can
do that by overriding configure
and here again we need to make sure that
we call
the super configure but let's first
ignore a path so we will take the web
configuration object
call ignoring passing and matchers for
slash
images
star star so anything under the image
directory should be ignored by spring
security and just served as it is
and then finally let's configure a user
for our system we can do that by
defining the user detail service
so user
details service
and here we're actually configuring a
bean so let's add a bean annotation here
as well
and we're not going to use super here
but we are instead going to use an
in-memory details manager
now this is not something that you would
ever want to use in a production
application but for this demo it's uh
very good in the von documentation you
can find examples of how to hook up to
an ldap or another authentication
provider for any actual application
usage
so
for this though we're going to just
create an in-memory user details manager
we're going to create a new
user with the builder so we're going to
say with username
user
then we're going to give it the password
since this is just a in memory demo
we're not even going to bother with
encrypting the password so we're going
to say no up
user pass as the password
then we're going to give it some roles
of user in this case only single role
and then finally call build
so what we have right now is a con
security configuration using the modern
web security configure adapter
setting the login view to our custom
login view
ignoring the image folder
from web security
and using a single user in memory with
the username user and password user pass
all right
so let's save and build and go to the
application and see what happens now
that we're on this spring security based
login page it's not going to have the
live reload so i'm going to navigate to
the app myself
and what you can see happens immediately
is i'm getting redirected to the login
page here which is what we would expect
because we've now secured the
application so let's try to log in user
user pass login
and we got logged in but we can't access
any
views so the last thing we need to do
here is actually
grant permission to views that we want
the user to be able to access so
open the sidebar here and let's go into
the
views here
so here i'm going to add a permit all
annotation saying that all logged in
users should be able to access this
and similarly for the list view we're
also going to add
a permit all annotation like this
so now
if this reloads we should be able to
access
the
list page and we are so still reloading
there we go
now we able to
go between these two
now we have a way of logging in the last
thing
kind of regarding security that i want
to do is add a log out button up here
so for that let's go back into the
security package and create a new java
class
security
service
and in security service or well first of
all let's remember to give this a
component annotation so we can auto wire
it
and
what i want to do here is do a public
method for
logging out so we call it log out and
here two things that we need to do first
will be
to get the current ui
get the page and set the location to the
path so we want to navigate the user to
the empty path after log out
then we're going to create a new
security context logout handler
context logout handler
like this pull it out into variable
we call it logout handler and finally
we're going to call
logouthandler.logout it takes in three
things the request response and
authentication but in this case we only
need to pass in
the
request we can get that from the vadin
serverlightrequest.getcurrent.hcp server
request
and
let me hide that and then pass null
values for the others because they don't
matter for this
okay so now that we have a service
method that we can call to log out
let's go into the main layout
and add that to our to our header
so here i'm gonna create a new button so
new
button
log out
and we'll have a
click listener so whenever gets clicked
we want to call the security service to
log out so for that to work we actually
need the security service so let's auto
wire it in here
security service let's call this
security service
create a field for it
and then call
securityservice.logout in the button
all right then we're gonna add this to
our
header here
the
well first first of all we actually need
to
pull this into a
into a
variable we'll call it log out and we're
going to add it here
all right so
save and build
and if everything goes well
we should have a log out button which we
have and when we click on it
we get logged out and sent back to the
login page
and we're able to log back in
so we've now successfully secured the
application and only permit access to
those who are logged in
our application is now basically
complete but there are still a couple of
things i want to do the first one is
configure how the application looks when
we install it and when it goes offline
and when we're done with that we're
going to take a look at testing the
application with unit tests integration
tests and end-to-end tests
okay but let's first take a look at
configuring the application installation
experience
so every one application is a
progressive web application by default
meaning that people that supported
browsers essentially most browsers these
days will be able to get an enhanced
experience where some things will be
cached automatically in the browser for
faster access and on many browsers
they're able to actually install the
application either on their desktop if
they're on a computer or on their mobile
device
you can configure
uh some pwa attributes here in the pwa
annotation on the application class so
i'm going to change the application name
here to
lot in crm
and give it a short name of crm so this
is the short name essentially what goes
under the icon on say mobile device
if the full name can't fit there
okay
the next thing i want to do is configure
the logo and update that to match our
application so for that again we're
going to go to the text version here
to the pwa chapter
and download both this image and this
image so that we have them
so once we have the images let's go and
put them in the right places in our
application
so
the first one we need to put under meta
in resources icons
so that would be
if we uh
make this a little bit bigger so we go
resources meta and resources icons
so we're gonna
drag
the icon here and replace the one that's
already there so
we'll overwrite that
and then the other thing is the offline
icon or image sorry and we're gonna put
this in the images directory here
so we'll move that there
and that takes care of that
okay so what i want to do next is
configure how the application behaves
when it goes offline so by default
you've noticed when i
sometimes when i refresh you see this
dark page saying that the application is
offline and uh you need to go online to
use it
but we can customize that page to kind
of match our application
and in in a real life situation that
gives a better user experience to the
to the user so we're going to have our
own custom html file for that and it
needs to be called offline.html
in the same resources folder
so we'll create a new
file here
offline.html
and we're going to paste in the content
that we copy from here
so what we have is a plain html
document
with some styles
pulling in this image that we just put
in there and have has a
custom
text here and finally it has a script
that listens for when the browser goes
back on or detects being back online and
that's going to reload the browser so
hopefully that will get us back into the
application
all right so let's configure these in
the pw annotation on the application
so we have our
let's put these on separate lines so
it's easier to see them
so we have the
offline resources here we have the
logo already made offline
and what we're going to add here as as
the other one will be
images
offline
offline.png
like that so that way we have that
we can also define the offline path
to be
offline.html so that the custom html
page that we have
gets picked up
right so let's save and build this
and go to the application
and we're going to wait for this to
reload
and
what i want to do is just verify that
these things got picked up so i'm going
to open up the developer tools and i'm
going to go
into the application tab here
and first thing i want to check is that
the manifest got updated so i can see
the
custom icon here but for some reason
this isn't updated yet so it seems like
something is still kind of getting
cached somewhere
so
one thing you might want to do is just
go ahead and clear the site data once
and refresh this to make sure that
everything
all the new stuff gets picked up now we
can see we have the correct icons here
and we should also be able to see that
there are some things cached here
for instance
our offline page
and we should also see our
offline image here
okay so now that we have those
uh let's
log in here user
user pass
what we can do as a user now is install
this application
so
depending on the browser the
installation experience will look a
little bit different but on chrome it's
up here in the nav bar
it'll ask if we want to install the app
we can go ahead and say yes we want to
do that
and what happens now is that you can see
that my application is here with its own
icon it's in its own window
and
now i can use it as a standalone
application so that's pretty cool
let's go ahead and check out the offline
page so i will go and turn off the
server
and then let's go ahead and
refresh here and see
so now
we can see that we're offline and we
have a custom offline page for that
so we've now turned the application into
an installable pwa
and we've customized the icon and the
offline page all right so with the
application completed let's take a look
at writing some tests i'm going to close
the standalone application here and just
open it up in the browser once again so
i'll just go to localhost 8080.
we're still offline so we can also go
ahead and start the application
all right um so what we need first of
all is a place for
the tests to live so up until now we've
only been working
here in the
source main
java folder which is where
our application sources live
what we're going to add now is a
separate test source route for tests so
here in the source folder we're going to
create a new directory called test
and
you can see intellij is actually already
suggesting that we create a test java
folder for maven
so this will essentially be a parallel
and identical
structure to the one we have with the
with the actual application source and
here it's actually really important that
we use the same exact package structure
because we're going to rely on package
access to some variables for testing
so let's go ahead and create
a package for the list view
so i'm going to go here to package and
create a
com
example
application
views
list package
so that will be exactly the same path to
the test as it is to the list view here
and in here we're going to create a unit
test that tests the contact form
now there's a little bit of setup here
so i'm going to go again into the
into the text version here and copy
the boilerplate and then we can go
through it together as you're copying
these you can go ahead and just
paste them straight on top of
of the package and intel j or your id
usually will take care of creating the
class
so what we have here
is a
test
that has a before annotated method here
for setup so before every test that we
run
we have a setup phase where we
instantiate all these fields to known
values that way we have a way of kind of
validating if the right thing happened
so what we have is a list of companies
and statuses
we have
a contact we have two companies and two
statuses that we want to check
so we instantiate the companies we add
two companies to it
we instantiate the statuses with two
statuses and then we create a contact
where we set the
status in the company okay so now that
we have known values for
all of these let's go ahead and create a
first test here i'm going to create a
public void method called form
fields
populated
which will
check that the correct form fields were
were populated so for this we're going
to create a new contact form
and pass in the companies and the
statuses
just like we would when we instantiate
it in the ui
we're going to pull this into a variable
we can call it form
and then what we will do is we'll set
the
contact here
to this known
contact that we have
mark usher
okay so then what we want to do is we
want to assert that the right values are
visible in the ui field so for that we
can use assertions
and we're gonna
assert
equals and we're gonna first of all
expect that the first name will be
mark and we're gonna get the
value from the form
first name field by calling getvalue
like this
okay
then
second let's
validate that
the last name is correct so we'll change
these to last name
then we'll do email
all right and next we'll do the company
so we want to make sure that
company two got selected so we'll get
the
company value and finally we'll validate
that the status
one
so the ones that we selected here
are
selected
all right and for this to become a
runnable test we need to add a
test annotation on it
and you can see at least in intellij you
know get this uh little help helper here
where you can run it so you can go ahead
and actually try to run this
and hopefully if things went well we'll
see that we get a
little green check mark here saying that
the form works the way we uh wanted it
to work
okay so now we
have a test that validates that the
right things get populated in the ui
let's create another test that tests
that we get the right values when we
modify something and save it
so for that let's create a new method
again
all right and we're going to annotate
this with a test annotation as well
so again let's create a new contact form
pass in
the companies
and the statuses
pull this into a
variable called form
and then let's create a new contact
we'll call this contact
and we set this empty contact to our
form so we call form dot
set to contact with this empty contact
that we have
and then we'll start populating the ui
fields programmatically so we'll get the
form
get the first name field from there and
then we'll set the value
value of that to a known value so we can
say something like
john
all right we'll do the same for the last
name
set the value to do
then we'll do the email
value
john.com
next we'll do
the
company and set the value to
a known company in our case we can set
the company one
and finally we'll set a status
to a known status so we can use
status 2 just to mix things up a little
bit
all right and as you remember when we
save something we actually get an event
back
so what we'll do is we'll create an
atomic reference where we can capture
that value that we get back from from
the event so we'll do a
atomic reference to a
contact
and we'll call this
saved contact
and we'll just instantiate the new
atomic reference
like this
in this case we don't have a initial
value
all right
then what we want to do is we want to
add a listener on the form so we can
capture that saved
contact so we'll add a listener
for the save
event
and
the event then what it will do is it
will take the
saved contact
and set the value to the
contact that we get from the event
like this
so that way we're able to pull out the
saved contact from there
and that's exactly what we'll do so
we'll
have our contact
we can call it saved
and that will be equal to the save
contact
dot get
so that way we now have a object here
which has all the information of that
saved contact and what we want to do
then again using assert
so that things are equal so we want to
make sure that the
john equals this the saved contact's
first name
do equals the
last name
john
doe dot com equals the
email
then we'll do the same for the company
in this case we'll use
company 1
should equal to the
company
and finally the status
i think we used status 2
should equal to the
status
like this
all right so let's try this again we'll
run this test and hopefully everything
goes well
okay so something did not pass let's
take a look at what's going on here all
right so cannot invoke
uh get first name because saved is null
all right that makes sense because i
actually forgot a pretty important
step here so we actually need to take
the
save button and actually click on it
for that
event to get triggered and for us to
have a saved contact so
let's save that let's rerun the test
and sure enough it passes
so now we've created two tests one
making sure that when we pass in a
contact the right fields in the ui will
get populated
the other one will start with an empty
contact
programmatically fill in the fields
click on the save button and make sure
that we get back what we expect now that
we have a couple of unit tests that test
the form by itself let's create an
integration test that tests the list
view and making sure that the
interaction between
these two components that it comprises
of
actually works so
create a new java class here and we're
going to call this list view test
and listview test will be slightly
different because we're gonna
use a
runner here so we're gonna define
run with and say that we're gonna use
spring runner dot class
so we're gonna use spring here so that
we can use auto wiring and stuff that
the view needs
and we're also gonna add a
spring boot test annotation
here all right so with those in place we
can now auto wire things here so we're
gonna
auto wire
in the list view
like
this and then let's create a new test so
for that a public
void
forum
shown
when
contact
selected so we want to make sure that
the form is shown when the contact is
selected and this will have a test
annotation on it
all right so you can see that this isn't
working right now because there are no
beans of type list view found so what we
need to do to fix that is go here and
add a component annotation and a
prototype scope so at a scope
roto
type like that
so that we always get a new version the
reason we didn't need to have these uh
earlier is that when we're navigating
through bottom vinyl will make uh take
care of actually
uh making sure that everything gets auto
wired but since we're not using widen
right now we need to make sure that
spring can find these on its own
all right so we'll go back into our
into our list view test and now you can
see that the error is gone
okay so what i want to do here is i want
to
find the first
person in the grid
select them and verify that the contact
form shows that right person
so for that we need a little bit of code
here so first of all
let's
use the list view to get the grid
and we can pull that into a variable
and then we want to find the first
contact so
let's do a method a little helper for
that so we can call get
first item on grid and that's going to
return the first item so we'll go ahead
and create this method this will return
a contact
and take in the grid
so the way we get the contact is by
calling grid and getting the data
provider
that's kind of what's holding on to all
those items
and we're going to cast this
into a
list data provider of type
contact
like this
and
then we can call
get items on this
get the iterator
and get the next contact from there
and then we can return this so now we
have a
way of pulling in the first item
from the grid
all right and we will
then pull this into a
variable we're going to call this the
first
contact
all right so now we know
who is the first contact here
then let's get the form so
list view dot form
pull that into a variable called form
then we'll do some assertions so first
we'll assert that the form is not
visible so we can use
insert again insert false
and we want to assert that form dot is
visible
is true all right
so
so once we know the form is hidden by
default we can take the grid
a single select
and set the value
to the first contact so we essentially
programmatically now select
this first item
then let's assert the form is visible
and that we actually get the right
person shown in the form
so
insert insert true
form that is visible so the form should
be visible then we'll insert
equals
that
the first contact that we know we have
that their first name is equal to the
form
first name field value
like this
okay so let's go ahead and run this and
verify that everything works
so one thing you notice here is that
this is taking quite a bit longer than
it did for the unit test that's because
we now have to actually start up the
spring di container
so there's a little bit of a trade-off
when you start doing this integration
test where you need to involve spring
but for the most part that's fine and it
allows you to test the application
integrations in a more realistic setting
so we can see that this now works we've
validated that the form is initially
not shown when we select the first
contact the form gets shown and the
first name
is valid so we can assume that the right
person got shown there and we have the
other unit tests that actually verify
that the form itself works
and then the final type of test that i
want to write for this application is an
end to end test so something that tests
the application all the way from the
browser to the database
we can do that using the bottom test
bench tool which again is part of the
button
pro tools so if you already started a
trial with the charts the same trial
will work for this as well
so let's set this up by going into the
test folder again and creating a new
package under application
called it
i t standing for integration tested the
end-to-end tests are essentially a very
wide type of integration test that tests
the entire application
there's a little bit of setup when we
create a testbench test so let's go to
the text version again
and copy over this abstract test that we
can use then to extend from
so we'll paste this over our new package
let's close some of these so we can see
what we have here
so the abstract test
defines some constants here for the
address and port
and it takes in a route
through its constructor
then it turns off some logging in the
apache http client so we don't get too
much spam in the console
and then it does some setup so before
the class starts it starts a chrome
driver
and if something fails it grabs a
screenshot and then the setup
essentially
gets the driver and opens up the url
that we want to test
so with that we can now start building
our first test
what i want to test is the login
functionality so i should be able to log
in with a valid username and i should be
denied login with a invalid username so
let's create a new java class for that
call it login it
the naming here is important because
maven uses the it
postfix to run these tests at the right
build phase so
create the new login id and then we can
start defining our test so first thing
we need to do is extend from abstract
test that we just created
and it will require us to
create the constructor
we don't want to pass in a route but
instead we're going to say that we're
going to be testing the empty route
so that takes care of the setup thanks
to the abstract test
now the next thing we want to do is
create an actual test so we're going to
create a public void
login as
valid user
succeeds
so this should
validate that a login with a correct
username and password succeeds
annotate this with a test so it becomes
runnable
and the way this works is that we can
use these element selectors to grab hold
of references to ui components in the
browser
in this case i'm interested in getting
the login form element
and
i want to get the first one that's
visible on the page in our case it's the
only one let's pull this into a variable
form
then let's set the values on the form so
we'll call form dot get
name field that set value user
then let's get the password field
set the value to user pass
and then finally
we'll get the submit button and click on
it and then what we want to assert is
that we're no longer on the login page
so what we can do here is
insert
assert false
that a new newer element selector for
the login form element that class
exists so we want to make sure that it
does not exist
okay so let's save this
and when we run these through the ide we
want to make sure that the application
is already up and running
that way we can run these tests quicker
because it doesn't need to start the
application every time when you're
running them through maven in the
integration test phase it will start the
server for you but that takes some extra
time that we don't want to do while
we're developing actively
when we run these it's important that we
run the entire class to make sure that
those all those
before class
annotated setup things get run so we'll
run the entire login it test here
and then let's see what happens
all right so something failed here um
all right
i'm gonna take a wild guess that it's
that this was made a protected method
let's try to make it a public
constructor just so it can get run
properly
let's run that again
and yes okay so now it opens up chrome
logs in
and sure enough we get a green check
mark here saying that everything went
well
all right so now we have one test that
validates that you can log in
successfully with the correct username
to make sure somebody can't log in with
an invalid password we could just copy
paste this whole thing
but something that you usually want to
do is create these elements for your own
views so that you can easily test
different variations without having to
copy paste too much code
so i'm going to create a sub package
here called elements
and inside of it i'm going to create a
login view element class
what we're going to do here is to find
some attributes
and we're going to say that the name
here will be a class
and it will
contain
login view
so in our login view as you remember we
added a css class login view and this
will help us find find the right one
then we're going to add an api here for
a method for logging in so public
uh boolean so we return whether or not
that worked and login is the method name
we'll take in two strings
user name and
string
password
then what we can do is essentially do
what we did here earlier
so let's
copy this over
move it here
and instead of
using these uh
these hard-coded values we'll
pass in the username
pass in the password
okay and the reason this is not working
is that actually forgot to extend from a
vertical layout element
and when we make these
elements it's really important that we
have the same class structure so if we
look at our
login view
you can see that it extends vertical
layout and has this class name
so we also extend from vertical layout
and then we use the class name here to
bind
all right so now we pass in the username
we're passing the password we click
and then finally we're going to change
the assertion so we're not going to do
an assertion here instead we'll
return
the negation of
a check of this login view element being
visible so we'll do a login view
element.class
on page
that exists
all right so now we do the same and we
validate that we no longer have the
login view
on the page
we can go back to the test that we had
here
and we can simplify this so what we can
do is we can
do
element selector for the
login view element
and get the first one of those
pull that into a
into a
variable so login view
and then we can
assert
that uh
the login succeeds so we can assert the
login view.log in with
user
and
user pass works
okay
so let's validate that first of all
continues to work so everything should
work the exact same way as it did just a
moment ago
chrome starts up it logs in and the test
passes
so now we have a easier way
to test that the opposite does not hold
true so login as
as
invalid user
fails so we'll do the same
but we
type something else here and we assert
that this would be
pulse of course so
now if we run this we should see two
green check marks
validating that this works
all right
and sure enough we have two green check
marks
so this is just a very quick
introduction to bond testbench so
you create a abstract test that you can
use in
as the base for just setting up all your
tests
and then you can create these elements
for your views to kind of encapsulate
some of the common things that you want
to do to avoid having to repeat yourself
too much and then finally you can just
do normal junit assertations on on
things that you expect to happen when
you run the code
now that we've created our application
and tested it the last thing that
remains to be done is to publish it
somewhere where we can share the link to
others
before publishing the application we
need to create a production build of the
application
we also don't want to use the in-memory
h2 database when we're running in
production instead we want to use a
postgres database
so let's do a couple of changes to the
code so that we can
get ready for deployment
first thing i want to do is go into the
maven palm file here and go into the
production
profile
so this is something that vauden
maven plugin comes with that we can use
to build a production
ready application so it minifies some of
the front-end assets it turns off
unnecessary debugging and in general
makes the application suitable for
production
so um
what i'm gonna do here is i'm gonna
add some dependencies
specifically for
uh for postgres so that when we're
running in
when we're running in production we want
to use postgres
so we're going to use postgres sql from
org postgresql like that
then we need to go into our
spring application properties and
define some
things here so i'm going to say
spring
jpa
uh dot generate ddl
is to true
and i'm also going to say in this case
spring
jpa
hibernate ddl auto to create drop so
this will create and then destroy the
schema at the end of the session now i
want to warn you that don't do this with
an actual application in a real life
situation you don't want to create and
drop the database every time you deploy
but for our demo purposes that's perfect
in a real life application you really
want to use something like liquid base
or flyway
to handle your database migrations so
that you don't lose data so keep that in
mind
all right so we now have everything that
we need the next thing that we want to
do is create a production optimized jar
so i'm going to open up a terminal
navigate to the desktop to the flow crm
tutorial and then i'm gonna run
the maven wrapper that comes with the
project
and i'm gonna
run the clean
and package
package targets and use the production
profile that we just configured
and this
will do a production build and the
result of that will be a jar file that
we can go and deploy
now while that's
doing its thing let's look at the
deployment here
in
in the text version so we're going to
deploy to heroku you can deploy modern
apps on any cloud provider or pretty
much any anything that runs a servlet
but heroku is a really easy place to get
started and it's free without requiring
a credit card so it's a it's a nice
place for us to
deploy to what you need to do is create
a heroku
account and you need to follow the
instructions for installing the cli
all right
so we now have
the package built here
and we can go ahead and start deploying
it to heroku
so the first step that you want to do is
log into heroku
with heroku login i've already done that
so i don't need to do that once again
the next step will be to run heroku
plugins install java so
plugins install
java so enable java for this app
all right
then we're going to create our
application
and we need to give it a name that's
unique so let's call this
button
crm tutorial
okay
and then let's create a add-on
to use postgres so
roku
add-ons
create
heroku
post
press
ql
and we need to pass in the app name
which in our case is
brought in crm tutorial
all right
that takes care of that
so now we're ready to actually deploy
this so we'll type in heroku
deploy
jar
then we find our
jar in the target so it'll be the
low crm tutorial
snapshot shot jar
then again we pass in the app name so
bought in
crm tutorial
and then we wait for this to to complete
it'll take a while when it sends over
the application
right you can see that
we are now deployed to heroku
at this address so we can
go to our browser and navigate to the
url
the first time it starts it'll take a
while for the app to actually boot up
and one thing to note with heroku is
that they do turn off their servers
after a little while of inactivity and
at least once
at least once per day so this might not
be
the kind of perfect solution for a
production deployment but it's really
great for an easy
way to get started so we have our app up
and running
so we'll type in user user pass
login
and sure enough here is our application
running on the internet
all right so there you have it we just
built a full sec web application in java
in just over two hours
let me know what you thought of the
course by reaching out to me on twitter
and also help share the words so please
share the video with any of your friends
or co-workers who might benefit from it
thanks for watching and i'll see you in
the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
you